humor is a fundamental part
of the existentialist ethic that's able
to deal with absurdity yeah you gotta
like laugh at it
i think there's some let me just say
something about humor because i think
you're absolutely right kierkegaard who
is danish and you know most people think
deeply depressed and so on
is actually an incredibly funny writer
and someone who was a classmate of mine
in graduate school who left philosophy
to become a hollywood comedy writer
uh he's very successful guy and then he
came back
25 years later and wrote finished his
dissertation and i was the the reader on
the dissertation but it may be a
conflict of interest i'm not quite sure
but but uh his dissertation was about
he called it kierkegaard and the funny
which is a
kind of a funny title yeah but but
kierkegaard according to eric kaplan's
reading kierkegaard has um
does have this idea that there's
something
destabilizing about humor
that's
crucial
to
the
sort of the important possibilities for
us and and so he there's the idea that
like there's a moment when a joke is
being set up
when you're sort of proceeding as if
you're on stable ground
and then the punch line comes
and the rug is pulled out from under you
and for a moment it's like you're
falling you don't
you you there's nothing supporting you
until you're captured by your totally
new understanding of what was going on
and that humor necessarily has that kind
of destabilizing
feature to it and that's like the
riskiness that's like the riskiness that
you were you're pointing to if if there
aren't risks in your life if your life
is totally safe
then there's no possibility of
significance
and so i think on eric's reading
kierkegaard sort of wants to line up the
importance of the riskiness and
vulnerability in your life to its having
meaning
with the experience of destabilization
that you get in jokes and comedy um
which then becomes significant right
that when you when you remember having
heard a joke for the first time it's got
a kind of salience
you